[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club round eight of the
spring classic here in st. Louis every
game in Group A was drawn leaving only
two players at the top grandmaster
Jeffrey Zhang has clinched at least a
first-place tie but he'll need to try to
score to stand alone apart from
grandmaster Verico bian who needs a win
as black today
meanwhile in Group B a black win for
grandmaster Victor Miko Levski
grandmaster priyadarshan can a pan beat
out catchy on to give the field a
three-horse race for round nine no
playoffs it will be settled in
regulation coverage of the final round
starts now with over $30,000 and pride
on the line 20 international chess
professionals converge in st. Louis for
the 2018 spring chess classic
hello chess fans and welcome to our
final day of the 2018 spring and chess
classic we're gonna settle the scores
today in groups a and B my name is Ben
Simon an advocate on a namer and in
Group A we already know that Jeffrey
Zhang has clinched a victory there will
be no playoffs in this event and so
really it's it's up to par Akopian to
see if he can tie Jeffery at the top and
Group E is a whole different situation
all together yeah definitely in goobie
everything is open we have a few a few
leaders over there so yeah we don't know
what's gonna happen
let's see how we got here the results
from last night in our masters division
yeah pretty simple
everybody drew it was a draw fest I know
no changes on the on the standings board
and now if we take a look at the
standings you'll see that those draws
leave only one contender who can match
Jeffery at the top now if Jeffrey scores
at all today
then well he's the lone winner six grand
to his name nice okay and as far as
group B goes we have the results from
last night
three decisive games and this puts three
players not necessarily in the three who
won last night in the top lead yeah we
have Viktor McCleskey beating Erin Grove
in ski we had Alexander fear beating
Josh temple luck and PD beating Melek
agenda rest and we have another two
draws and the standings will show that
no one has clinched this division yet
although Michael of ski is very very
close to doing so if let's say the
collapse key loses okay if he loses in
can a pan draws and gore Yvette's wins
we could have up to a three-way tie for
first in Group B I know that's that's
pretty crazy and as we said before
usually it was it was more at the
overtime group a because of the ratings
but the rankings were much closer here
then I think the spread was much higher
in the ratings but as you can see it's
much much closer so
yeah we're gonna see some fight today
and not around nine this site decides it
all very tally would you prefer to see
multiple winners or just one winner in
each division um no no it's a good
question
it's a good question I guess maybe just
one me too yeah yeah we're gonna come
out and say we never see one win now I
mean group a is cut dry that's Jeffrey
yeah otherwise otherwise we have to
calculate you have to take out our
calculators divided prizes yeah some
excellent work I've been I'm ready for
it I have the numbers in front all right
well that breakdown at the end all right
but let's take a look at the games that
are happening right now on us chess
champs calm in the masters division and
I'll tell you no one that we're looking
at today that the five key players the
two in Group A and the three in Group E
none of them are playing each other so
that's that's a little bit of a downer
and instead of more of a head-to-head
boxing match it's more of a foot race to
the finish and here's what we have going
on today in Group A we have yellow job
of playing SW spirits Jeffrey don't
think playing us Alex only shook Alex a
path of playing versus or man Edward so
react and ghuli versus Sam Shanklin and
Lazaro Brazil is playing against America
beyond now make no mistake vitally
Jeffrey Zhang's game against Alex
ownership is important Jeffrey's gonna
try to pull away from the pack pull away
from var to be specifically and claim
first place all to himself but because
he's already clinched first at least a
tie I say the game of the day has to be
Lazaro bruised own against vara cobia
who at as black has got to win to see a
spot at first with Jeffrey Jean yeah by
the way besides this game we also have
as I said we have a Jeff is young
playing against Alex only shook now Alex
only shook will probably try to do his
best
still to beat Jeffrey Jones just
together at the top not the first place
but at least our the top so we're gonna
see those two games very very deep
fighting we see vodka beer is going to
try to win probably with four and a half
points however as you can see Volvo is
going to be playing with black pieces
now a Lazaro zone is that
the same position as Alexander Hani
shook he has only four points so they
are all gonna give it all out today
in fact per zone could surpass Akopian
final standing definitely yeah so you
know you know for example if vara
command is gonna offer a draw to tube
razón I don't think that he's going to
talk said that I think he's gonna is
going to play to the death and now let's
take a look at the pairings for Group B
remember these rounds the rounds started
two and a half hours ago and it's really
breaking down fast so let's not waste
too much time on this but there you can
see the players none of the top three
Mika Levski gora bets canna pan those
top three games right they're not
playing each other so it will be a race
to the finish and they they all have
staggered points six five and a half and
five so kind of dynamic here yeah
anything spread out and the game of the
day though has to go with the guy who
does have the lead
Viktor McCleskey of Israel going up
against Brazilian Grandmaster Alexander
fear if mija Levski wins then shut yeah
yeah that's that's that's the first
place is his now as I was saying before
obviously get master Alexander fear
again although he probably cannot fight
for the first place but he will still
try to get to climb up to the second to
the first half or the the first five
places so he will also try to beat
Viktor and this is the final day of the
2:10 player around Robbins and let's
take a look at the time control its game
in while it's 90 minutes for the first
40 moves there is a 30-second bonus
added to both players clocks after the
40th move and there is a 30-second
increment from move number one there is
a 30 move draw rule in effect the
players cannot agree to a draw before
the 30th move which allows for some good
fighting chess and once again there are
no playoffs in this event let's take a
look at the prizes real quick in Group A
there is a $22,000 prize fund at
six grand goes to the winner four grand
for second place and and in Group B the
prizes are pretty good too up to a
fourteen thousand dollar prize yeah and
as you can remember we discussed
conditions before now I think that's one
of the other conditions that we provided
here at HS Club is the dinner we have a
dinner afterwards it's a pretty nice
place we do it on the street
yeah vodka bar right Ali I'm getting
word that Viktor Mika Lipsky has won his
game oh my god against Alexander fear
moments ago oh wow let's let's glance at
it really quick and we're gonna that
means that Michalowski is the winner
yeah means groupie Wow congratulations
Soviet Lansford and we're gonna talk to
him in just a few perfect man we're not
wasting any time
look at this I know let's see Viktor was
a very sharp game yeah I'm not surprised
that the game actually ended ended so
fast I mean I assume that's Victor
probably prepared very well to the game
probably played you know pretty fast to
try to put some psychological pressure
on his opponent and yeah I mean good for
him was let's let's see what this is the
final position in the game it looks like
the last move that the victim made it in
the game taking with the bishop here on
d2 just taking this pawn away now let's
see the final position I mean this the
Queen here is attacked on e85 is
attacking that this this Queen if the
Queen takes the bishop then we can
simply take on b8 checking the black
King and obviously we will promote and I
don't see any chance for black for
perpetual check or anything like that
now if the Queen will try to take the
pawn then I assume that instead of
taking the bishop on on b8 we can
probably play Bishop to c3 with a check
too
to the king and this is pretty much lost
and now I would like to welcome the
winner of the beating of the be a group
yeah
victim with Alaska congratulations thank
you it was pretty fast for the first
game the first one that finish today
you're like okay I'm just gonna tell
everybody relax guys might the first
place is mine no you can guys keep
playing but you know like I got in here
and probably feeling pretty good right
now all right
being so quickly intervene at all I mean
yeah but I was saying before the game
that probably for Alexander fear even
though he's not a contestants for the
first place he was probably also trying
to win to play for a win he wouldn't
want a draw right because that won't
give him any chances to get to the top
some some of that prizes yeah and he's
the top-rated player in the tournament
anyways right right that's that's true
right very nice
well congratulations let's look at at
your game I assume that you were
preparing before now okay he was
well-prepared and he played most of the
game like please really yeah okay I
spent most of my okay interesting okay
so don't prepare and you win the first
place okay
interesting interesting idea we have a
fall for Victor
okay so default you've started the game
with t-49 f6 Knight of 3 is 6 and now c4
so we are in the Queen's Indian and d5
kind of transposing and now to the
Catalan g3 a lot of Israeli players like
to play the Catalan yeah there's a
check-in before it's pretty much all
dealing castle castle c6 so he decides
not to take you on c4 which probably one
of the other lines no usually they take
on c4 visibly chiffons he wants okay
here's the sixes
right okay so c6 Queen to c2 Bishop 24
moved to d1 Bishop a 693 five so I
assumed you knew this by pretty well as
well yeah I think this should be serious
if I know well okay Roxy and then after
six he surprised yes he takes and he
surprised me with 99 a place C takes d5
yeah make much more natural yeah and the
knight c6 no 96 yes so what's the idea
just to take any eight and two bishops
we're happy with two bishops right so
that probably shows us that when he took
here with the knight is trying to
complicate things
yeah for sure okay so I thought for a
long time before taking on c6 but I
think that's the critical way to play
yeah because if you bring the bishop
back then it's maybe losing some tempos
yes so 96 a brave move I mean I gotta
say without any preparation to put it
yourself okay
good night before yeah and here it's
important to play Queen a4 I believe and
now because they can only seven was also
notion about Queen takes now if I play
Queen the foreskin simply takes it upon
right
the sequel material should be good for
like right yes we need for first and now
the queen is under attack on jail right
so here there's not time to take the
pony - mm-hmm so he took on c6 if you
place b5 instead
also consider this because then if I
take indeed he takes only four and my
night is pretty much threat right now so
but I would probably play Knight xd7
check Korean takes is seven and Queen a5
yeah now it looks like this would be
five Israeli stuck in his bishop over
here yeah but I mean the idea is to play
Knight c2 but then I believe I can just
take the bishop on e6 Knight takes a 1
and Bishop d6 Bishop d6 yeah it's pretty
good yeah I've been back some material
and doesn't work that's why he took on
statistics looks like you're calculating
very well yeah any tips subtle for for
the viewers of how hard to calculate
just play lots of games just practice
yeah okay yeah instead of Queen a6 I
also considered Bishop takes c6 that's
another option Bishop takes 2
I wrote key one and in the beginning I
thought this should be good for a while
because two pieces a engines and I don't
listen and the bishop on e2 but he says
b5 initially I thought he should take
yes but he has a strong intermediate
move Knight b6 Oh another one
listen this square yeah I should play
the Queen eighty-six Bishop takes b5
green takes b5 and then he means back
the d4 pawn is fine
yeah even before him straps yeah so
where what did he slow down never stop
down okay okay I was wondering you're
like well until when his preparation but
right now we moved number 14 okay
interesting
so take on a 695 in fact that's what I
missed from but you know if if he's
playing fast and he's telling his
population it still it tells you that
you are doing the right moves can go
down either way instead of 95 I consider
it night before night before
yes I D is to play 92 in an exchange but
I can play at least queen takes a 7 92
93 and I get two points for exchange
very strong bishops I thought only white
can play for me
last game that we that you with so
viewers they also sacrifice the exchange
you like with the bishops yeah okay so
95 cannot take because of the bishop is
hanging yeah yeah so I have to play
Quincy for if I go queen is three
instead then he just takes from before
and now he's threatening me son
discovery at attacks like 92 93 no and
if I play Knight c3 she can't even play
a5 not my queen is yeah simply wants to
play Knight C to rotate rotate and the
Queen strip oh very nice yes yes and so
I went to c4 Knight a5 Queens history so
here I decided to sacrifice the Queen
for Sorokin night they have rook Bishop
and the pole it was a queen which is a
belief more than enough in this position
he was still blitzing vaporization
Queen d7 his protecting the a 7-pound
sir she wants to take on BC such as
protected 92 Roxy was more or less
forced he's attacking c3 I can place a
simple rope D 2 c1 and they believe
white is fine but now it was already
more aggressive and so I played before
Knight see for his first Knight takes
rook takes and here in fact I have two
options i can play b5 with the idea of
Bishop c6 y between takes and rook takes
a 7 also looks very promising
yeah but I wasn't sure if you please
after b5 g v g5 okay yeah just here -
about to get an escape square enforcer
King base so you have to go you can
still play Bishop c6 inside yeah and
then then he can just take Roxy 6 BC 6
Queen c6 okay now we get to rooks versus
Queen I can even take the a7 poem I
thought broke a 7 maybe she takes the
four robbed X is 7 and something like
either take so Quincy serious the past
poem Quincy
I didn't want to enter complications
yeah the chances of - energy for white
is almost zero if you cannot leave this
probably this position yeah yeah I
thought it's better to play d5 nice
break in the center the deep on one the
game yeah because now all of my pieces
are extremely strong okay I assumed that
this was already not his preparation
this is moving about 23 yeah
probably that's when he started singing
35 yeah we did not expect d5 although it
yeah yeah yeah I'm not sure what he
missed in his preparation rotate c3 so
yeah if I take 35 the dissertation
everything looks pretty dangerous yeah
okay so fix it 3-3 Bishop h3 some now I
just want to take only six with a double
attack right and it's very difficult
and then the so he played the five to
block the diagonal and then II for
opening up the position those this
Bishop is almost there what pond in the
Queen very tough this Bishop and g6 I
can just take everything like dt x e6
Queen takes is six she takes it takes a
five story she takes the five rook you
want or even maybe rookie I wasn't sure
yeah looks pretty deadly
yeah Ice King is very yes he takes F
takes e4 and then okay so announce the
rooks and syrup DC yeah this looks like
the only chance to trade the pair of
rooks but his problem is that he loses
by force I can also play rook c1 and
with a big advantage the ox is seven
yeah seven extends a bishop you'll stand
on f6
yeah but the address thought its winning
the ship she - inside is 2 PI R ok a
different Lisa Bishop I didn't really
see chief wife is his only chance to
push my if I go to G tools and maybe he
plays Queen h5 his chance with Lady of
Quincy one check some perpetual checks G
for the point is to cover the AFC square
so when I play rook e8 Bishop Jade and
Bishop g5 and then take indeed he
promotes with G - I don't have
disability
very complicated so ok let's see that's
it so G fo if you do this ok for this I
don't have a threat of taking so he can
play like maybe King be seven let's show
this although even here if you put if
you play this 71 you should pay for one
maybe King give seven yeah this would be
a torture to play yeah actually I don't
know who is thankful for win here but
it's pretty difficult for yeah probably
it said Robert yeah I take the d6 pawn
and just do nothing
yeah exactly yes just portraits of
bishops I just played Bishop h6 so I
started playing for me now my idea is to
play Bishop g5 and then repeat
and then he cannot maybe should be
because of e70 right say this should
before yes I did if I play rock I eat
he takes takes and place t2 and again I
cannot stop the pony LightSquared bishop
yeah and this would be probably a job
maybe I still have been in chances but
again I have something better than this
yeah yes I just played Bishop d5 I
expect it in fact Bishop before so
here's the point is safely place if he
still plays d2 i play seven check King
Gatorade Bishop takes D to now he cannot
take say seven poem because of Bishop CC
and if you take some t2 then I play rook
e8 we need Bishop in it and he cannot
stop me my very logical lots of
calculations so how much how much time
did you have when you like three minutes
three minutes and how much did he have
over an hour Wow okay
Bishop d6 then okay engage it and Bishop
f7 I believe is the most precise
yeah if I attacked from the other side
like Bishop c6 then she plays d2 Bishop
takes d2 Queen e7 which still loses but
yeah I can play Bishop c3 check in fact
can you cheat Bishop d5 check and then
still
too much too much the bishops in a row
yeah but coming from f7 is much simpler
because he doesn't have the verb for the
king
so d2 Bishop d2 and now if he takes only
sevens and Bishop CC okay well
congratulations for the win
congratulations for winning the first
place is that your first time that
you're winning here in st. Louis okay
yes yes of course
how did you enjoy it so far so far the
conditions were good conditions for
excellent probably the best David yeah
of course of course so hopefully we'll
see you see you again we also we also
have a dinner afterwards hopefully we'll
see you there
congratulations on you winning you know
what what you're gonna do with the prize
money joy in your life okay
all right well congratulations and I
hope to see you again and we are going
to go to a short commercial break
[Music]
as the st. Louis chess club celebrates
its 10th anniversary the US
Championships returned to st. Louis for
the 10th straight year
this April America's best players
descend on st. Louis to play for the
country's top honor Wesley so and sabina
Poyser will be defending their
championships as they face an all-star
field
don't miss America's best battle it out
at the st. Louis chess club celebrating
10 years of promoting teaching and
playing the game of chess for tickets
and more information go to st. Louis
chess club org
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get 24
by 7 coverage of chess news and events
access to premium analysis and
commentary and the chance to interact
with grandmasters and other top players
and coaches get advised from the best
and even challenge them to a battle be
the best chess player you can be it's
time to level up your game with chess 24
Premium Membership
there's a weekend vacation on one tank
trip in a nearby city you wanna be
surprised
be intrigued be delighted the world
chess Hall of Fame in st. Louis is
nothing you'd expect and everything you
love three galleries highlight the
history culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagined it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
[Music]
you could fly to Venice
or Paris
or even combination
you could fly all over the world the why
when you can just come to st. Louis your
trip begins at explore st. Louis calm
hello chess fans and welcome back to the
2018 spring chess classic I'm Vitaly
namer
and we have another guest announce to
you today a Jeffrey Zhang who just
finished finished his game right now
beating Alex and alone issue with the
white pieces Jeffrey congratulations
how do you are you feeling I mean to win
any event is really nice but especially
yeah of course I assumed we were not
expecting going to this event to win
this so congratulations your first time
you win such in such an event here in
st. Louis I mean I played in the two
editions so far and and those I did not
so great so yeah this would be the first
win for me yeah and especially you had a
sound first wins over some of your
opponents I know that about carbon for
example it was your first win what about
Alex an issue how how are you going with
him so far I played two games in I had
black and I was suffering in both games
and I managed half out of two yeah sweet
sweet revenge well good for you good job
so let's go let's go to analyze your
game I assume that obviously you
prepared for the game you came here to
win I was saying that you know somebody
like Alex on this should probably also
came to win came to win the game I mean
even if you would offer him a draw this
you would not accept he needs to try to
get to the top so it would be you know a
very sharp game so let's see what what's
happened in your game today
you play d4 96 c4 e6 and g3 c5 and d5
yeah here actually he usually doesn't
play the
I don't know the lesson he's actually
plated so yeah once he played c5 I
already knew that he came in with some
ambitions right maybe to complicate
things
the banana is definitely more unbalanced
opening so d5 but I'm sure that you you
can't prepare as well context on d5 this
has been much old theory g6 Knight to c3
g6 now we just don't supposed to the
regular Banani Castle castle a six a
four to start be fine yeah now I'm not
sure if what he did was a fashionable
set up but actually I had a game against
nvl and and in blitz on Chester come in
he played something quite similar and I
think it's an interesting idea because
it puts the Queen on the c7 and so like
no no he played rook e8 here yeah yeah
this Queen of seven is actually probably
better place than on e7 because he has
these ideas of playing 94 now and
recapturing with the rook or you can
play seats in five c4 so yeah though it
looks like it's kind of pinned in front
of the bishop it might be even better
there exactly
I think so if you go with the game I
think he actually got a pretty good
position so how did he build a began
with n VL the other game no went in a
slightly different move order like I
played rook e1 and but it was kind of
similar place was it was a thing that
that's that the game that Alexander was
preparing for I'm not 100% Queen d2 it's
pretty standard yeah so here yet I think
defy may was over a few cities if he
goes c4 I think
advantage yeah I can't I can't allow
this night to jump in I think I have to
play b4 anyway probably a pissant takes
takes night c5 and I was planning look
before and at least I didn't see
anything so nice for him I mean he he
has this 94 and then maybe some problems
but I think I can just take in Rick see
one is very important Brooksie one okay
yeah maybe maybe this is what he
actually didn't like because Queen 85
runs into relief force and it's an issue
oh nice
so that's why yeah maybe then go for but
I have a feeling that black probably has
something anyway can a play can eat it
prepare this with Bishop f5 or something
yeah [ __ ] for five is new but then I
think I was gonna go G for this if I go
here yeah now I just take and probably
maybe the same thing maybe not I can
also play will see one yeah nothing
changed
it's the same trick in Queenie fun okay
maybe instead of 94 you can go [ __ ]
before I think this is the one I was
looking at Bishop e4 I mean I mean oh
maybe this is also playable I was
thinking after G for Bishop they
actually know but actually this is
better yeah so 94 take with the bishop
use looks looks like a double-edge game
I mean you're gonna put your open c1
probably guess and but blood speeds are
quite well-placed or anything very
active I mean he has this nice long day
the question is what to do next I mean
he's born d6 quite hanging let's just
form b7 so interesting game was you guys
made it here so instead he played b5
immediately but yeah b5 I think now I
take him before I mean this is very
typical and then I thought he would go
night age 5 and then just rage sticks
and I think I mean I'm not sure I think
he has to take yes it take take take and
now I have a choice I actually have a
few words and go 9594 I could go tonight
a to many many possibilities and I
wasn't sure lots of tactics yeah so I
wait how are you learn time in this game
living here I think I was still behind
slightly on the clock in this moment but
yeah this is probably show gone for it's
kind of unclear but in the game I think
he's just worse cuz now I just taken a
g5 and I didn't see how to play for
because yeah here he spent a lot of time
and then he he moved group II ate can
you he's had to do something before it's
an isolation with the background i me
feel take on before if you think some
before i think they'll just take
problems would be six yeah suddenly this
Bishop on on c8 is yeah yeah this
problem in the position I mean so 95
rookie a 94 I think sacking the exchange
it's not sufficient compensation I
thought maybe you can try Bishop e5 but
it looks very suspicious if you take
then you have to stick to the a rock
right yeah maybe like four or five and
you go something like that nice so I'm
gonna decide a sack but I don't think
it's sufficient
yeah and I decided to play in the most
simple way to exchange this very
powerful Bishop on g7 so first i
provoked bishop aid sheet and then I
went back and now I gave him this pawn
h3 because I think first of all it's a
very good pawn to sacrifice because I
might have some ideas on the age 5 yeah
this was a nice when you were going or
going forward and backwards just still
putting his bishop on the chain right
yeah just making a more passive Bishop
d4 Bishop takes Queen takes and takes on
h3 but now he probably has too many
weaknesses here on the docks exactly
yeah and also the main problem is now I
can go unclaimed you do rotate one and
he can't really contest this very
crucial 8127 and on night a4 there's
always a bishop c2 you can sit over here
to exchange the bishop so that's I was
but I I thought the only way I can
justified is if I can get an immediate
assault on the edge file but I didn't
really see it like you take this and you
want to just sacrifice yes
I'm probably still better but I was kind
of afraid maybe you can play Queen d7
too suspicious
I can't bow neck and just still snap
this I don't know these Queen is here I
mean maybe you can still do it actually
just takes Queen takes rook h1 me I
started as Queen g7
I'm just over there yeah right I
preferred yeah I preferred what I did
because his bishop becomes a target
action
Queenie 7/4 there okay one you got the
control over the a file h5 well he needs
to try something otherwise yeah I mean
all these pieces are kind of tied up
there's no coordination within the
pieces
rokay six but what to do no risk no
reward right so he's playing with risky
depend on he's always very sharp an h4
yeah I think if he didn't he didn't like
I mean nine a for Bishop c2 or 97 I just
double look so he just didn't like so an
idea for you would see though no Bishop
see to preserve see tonight is lost yeah
yeah so after okay six h4 and you cannot
take the night because you're gonna lose
the bishop so Bishop f3 not Queen b7
yeah I thought he had to try what he did
9 a 4 takes Queen said maybe hope that
yeah eventually get his pawns going on
the Queen said like c3 before I can made
him but unfortunately the problem is
let's say instead Bishop d7 he tries to
take on d4 the problem is I've got King
f2 and our work h1 is just game over
so yes the trade Queens probably queen
c3 but now the issue is I can just steak
and play G for this Bishop is yeah
that's the whole problem of the game
this bishop what to do with him can't
live with him can't live without him ok
so instead they played Bishop d7 so he
was trying to activate the bishop but
then he got pinned Queen d2 d 6 plate
and Queen to a force they were ready to
get endgame obviously you need to
protect a g-type on route to b6 King to
g2 is did still you have someone bishop
even without the Queen's
we're just to force make just a foursome
to take on our floor
so came to f8 e 4g e7 yeah actually I
missed his idea of bringing the King in
because maybe if I don't have rook a 7
he's actually on fighting on like here I
had real case unfortunately and it's
over but if I don't have real p7 I'm not
sure because then I don't really see
so he's idea just to baby came to b6
exactly yeah so if I take maybe he
actually had some chances now because he
controls the e5 a thing like if I take
rookies and then f6 right okay seven
yeah that's perfect move right f6 rook
h1 finally you came became your plan
worked and the H file won't on the game
oh very nice way nice so congratulations
on you win
Jeffry and please tell us do you have
any any no no how are the conditions
here in the in the tournament did you
enjoy it
yeah I mean it's it's always a pleasure
to play hero just one of the best values
in the world and always happy to play
nice and I know that your dad is
traveling with you I think it's a big
support probably yeah graduations what
is your what are the next steps they
have any other upcoming chess
tournaments coming in yeah surely the
next one is also right here of the US
Championship of course most procedures
from over here for me and
hopefully I can maintain this formula
that I have now yeah yeah definitely it
looks like you're on fire and the last
question you know when I was when I was
17 years old if I would get you know
fifty bucks it would be good so what is
a 17 years old
going to do with a $6,000 dad decide
okay sounds good well hopefully you can
see your dinner today have an amazing
dinner for the participants of the
tournament and again congratulations and
thank you for I guess I want to
congratulate st. Louis Archbishop's on
their win and in the pro league and all
the other seven teams who managed to
qualify yeah so you're playing actually
so I play for Dallas yesterday we were
playing some new pandas and it was a
very tough match unfortunately they
finished eighth and they had the draw so
congratulations to them and good luck
next round yeah how would you describe
you know when you have to play two
tournaments at the same time how is that
well I mean I think it's always exciting
to have I mean obviously you have the
candidates going on right now I'll be
checking that pretty soon and I think
it's just very exciting for the
spectators to get to take in so much
great chess everywhere
exactly exactly well congratulations
again and good luck in your next to
limit we are going to go into a short
commercial break as the st. Louis chess
club celebrates its 10th anniversary the
US Championships returned to st. Louis
for the 10th straight year
this April America's best players
descend on st. Louis to play for the
country's top honor Wesley so and sabina
Poyser will be defending their
championships as they face an all-star
field
don't miss America's best battle it out
at the st. Louis chess club celebrating
10 years of promoting teaching and
playing the game of chess for tickets
and more information go to st. Louis
chess club org
[Music]
the question on Twitter from dem s I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a champion for those of you who
are new to chess it might look like pa3
is an illegal move here because white
advances pawn to square is not one but
it still is something we call hustle and
you can do that by you have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move like
let's say play King in seven kimchi -
and now try because four against
Lawrence and now he's going to play
something against me which we discussed
the flame during the course of my stay
yeah he told me this is that g5 this was
what I was kind of hoping for because
now I think we might as well know who
Lawrence
this is not how chest works certainly
would be much much more fun if
Chatterjee to work like this
I don't think it does well maybe it does
well that's me regretting what I just
said how did I get from there to here is
a little bit beyond me
and what's worse I will never hear the
end of it my quality of life has just
gone downhill tremendously because I'm
actually sharing the office of the guy
[Music]
you
[Music]
and welcome back to coverage for the
2018 spring chess classic this is the
final round
and I'm Ben Simon an advocate a murmur
and it's good to see you again by tally
you too
it's been a little bit we had both of
the winners finished their games first
out of both fields that's kind of
unusual usually you see those games play
out but the winners dominated their
games in early fashion yeah yeah as we
said the ninth round we were expecting
very sharp games and it looks like all
of them were playing pretty fast just
psychologically to you know to take take
the opponent off out of this track so
yeah you know it no risk no reward so we
were playing risky but looks like
Geoffrey and Geoffrey and the nicoleff
ski they both stood their ground and
finish the first place they didn't need
a playoff and good thing is we didn't
have one the undisputed winners now
Geoffrey was talking about the pro chest
league and for those of you who don't
know Pro actually stands for
professional rapid online chess like it
grew out of the US chess League which
was a Craig pardon me
Greg Shaha days baby it's an online
chess league and the US chess league was
all these had all these cities from
around the u.s. competing online and
that's where the st. Louis Archbishop's
started and I'm sure Mike comer will
appreciate Jeffrey's shout out to the
Archbishop's but the Archbishop's have
carried over into the successor it's
even bigger its batter it's better and
it's on chess calm the pro chess League
and yeah you can check it out chess calm
Jeffrey part of the Dallas destiny it
was an action last night so that and
that's why we are ending earlier these
last two rounds is actually for approach
s League the players that do have
commitments with different teams I do
feel like we have so many just limits
nowadays going on also the candidates at
the same time yes the candidates in
person in Berlin the Spring Classic here
in st. Louis the protest League online
all over the world it's always example
court the
has done yes
let's jump back to we still have some
games going on for the second place and
focus for all other places and let's
jump back to the game of the day in
Group A which is played by Lazaro Brazil
versus accordion for Akopian so Wow I
really like this position I have no idea
who is battle here but it looks like
everybody's attacking everybody at first
I liked white position because white
looks like white has more space because
of the pawn here on e5 but on the other
hand look at look at black pieces this
pawn on b3 you know it's like a bone in
our throat we really can't get it out of
there and those those pieces really
block hitting all of White's pieces oh
oh it's apples it the way around okay I
can't figure out who is blocking
blocking oh well I was looking at it
from I mean from White's perspective it
it looked like white was being
suffocated but they you know if you look
at it the other yeah yeah exactly
well right now it looks like black is
the one with the plan to attack on the
Kings side I don't see a way for white
for Lazaro to break on the Queen side so
I feel like the king on c8 is supposed
to be slightly safer than the King on h1
let's see how did we get to this
position so this position you know most
of the close position they come from the
French defense we have very closed pawn
chains over here and c5 c3 everyone is
trying to keep their pawn pawn chain
nice and neat and we don't want to break
up on chain that is over it is over
shake hands I would assume it's a draw
because I don't think that yeah it looks
like a draw
hmm I really wanted to see some more
fighting can't predict anything today we
get to one live game and they decide to
call it a day
what do you think that do you think that
jeffrys win
influenced various decision for the for
agreeing to a drop
probably but as I mentioned Burroughs
own had only four points and I was
expecting maybe razón to try to win this
game however as you can see as we said
that he was playing white his clock he
had only one minute on the clock to make
the next ten moves and it looks like
this attack is coming here on the King
and I really feel like white had many
many difficulties here in the position
so probably what happens that the vodka
been played this move Bishop to b5 and
saying well you know I I can probably
offer draw just to secure my second
place and you know with without any of
the bloodshed to be spilled here right
yeah Things Considered yeah
so it's a good job so I think can can
somebody tie for second with with Varro
I think I think he probably is the only
one or at least he is sharing it
Sam Shanklin it stands with four out of
eight so he can
darah spirits also the same situation
actually yeah some people can still time
with Haley yeah Edouard sure book
spirits and Shanklin if my quick
evaluation is correct
hmm well be interesting to see because
you know if if if a Cobian is going to
share this place with lots of players
yeah you might look back and say well
why did I get for a draw it could be a
couple yeah better that is the case okay
hey okay let's go back to group be
catchy an Angora bits this is this is a
game that we said was important coming
into today
whenever Corbett's it with a win could
maybe tie for first that's not the case
anymore but still an important game and
it looks like Andre is doing well yeah
exactly I mean first of all Ronda is
just with a piece up now this Bishop and
this type do not look so so well as well
this is this key
of seven I'm not sure everything sure
how they got to this position a very
peculiar position it looks to me but the
the the key idea is that after this move
Queen to h6 black wants to play a rock -
eh - it just made white so white has
played here Queen to c6 there is no way
for for white - two defenders and let's
look at let's look at what's going on
look at the class oh yeah look at just
at the clock it yes Andrey has 30
seconds and medic has two minutes we are
only at move number 25 oh my god and
they're only gonna get this that second
time control at 40 moves guys so 15 more
moves to go and they have a 30 second
increment to play on not a lot this is
where this is well you know Blundell's
happened so Andre - the Ponte home
before he decided not to check the King
we can always check the king of h2
because probably if I check on h2 King
g1 well there is no check on h1 because
the Queen is defending it at the square
here on h1 but right now Bishop took on
before and black is asking right well
what do you have I mean I'm just all
defended let's try to check out the
seven so this would be my first
candidate full but in this case the
knight can go to e7 and luckily for us
this pawn on e6 is defended by the Queen
and black is going to ask white well
what do you have I mean I'm a peace at
peace and actually peace and three pawns
excuse me so recently pawns are four
yeah that's it
it's a bishop and three pawns and it
looks almost hope hopeless for medic
very decisive games would you believe
that the last round would be the most
decisive one look I mean judging I know
this is not a Norma cific tournament but
a one of the tournaments that is
familiar or similar to this is the Norma
beds and in the last round you see maybe
like the two key games going really
really late and then all the other games
are drawn really or exactly but when you
have more money on the line yeah
and it's not so much about the norms
that this this stuff can happen this
this is not still unusual though I
didn't expect this today right right and
you know I always like to finish the
tournament with a win even let's say you
lost you know you're behind you're 2 out
of 8 it's still like when you win the
last game three out of nine is not a
good result but it's still you feel good
coming out of the tournament so I think
that this is what the players are trying
to achieve today trying to do the best
so it is antlers move again so after
Bishop took on before medic played
Knight to d3 going backwards and now I
wonder again what about those checks on
h2 and I think that Android did play
move he played Knight to e7
the machine says that the tundra missed
a mate in 11 how could he miss her
better than well only 40 seconds that's
so easy
but even after night is also at home
right 97 but it looks like black will
still be winning white needs to move the
Queen somewhere and let's try to cool to
move the Queen to b7 still somehow
defending this disparage on h1 let's
check let's see the idea and probably
Queen h4 so now I want to come here to
g3 and there is almost no defense almost
no defense it's under his move again as
well as let's let's refresh the board it
was played 97 could be Queen d7 rock h2
and let's see if and Drake is going to
touch the Queen and move it to h4 it is
is a little bit unsure there's a lot of
lots of money on the stake over here for
this game and I think it was the Queen I
wonder if you played the Queen - looks
like it it's the Queen went to h3 it did
go to h3 now we went from a firm mate in
the 11th to making 15 he Edward it is
over shaking yes yeah good game ok so
what does it mean for our standings
Gaurav 8 something will be taking the
second place probably well you know
don't forget about canna pan champion is
black against and black mm-hmm but it
may not be too much in PD's favor
Corbett's yeah is in second place right
now with six out of nine but we'll see
we'll see how priyadarshan can do and
see maybe if words can take clear second
yeah let's look at the options game then
if only discussed his game we've got
we've got more results here in Group E a
wonderland
Shondra have drawn their game putting
the kibosh on a wonders tournament and
well Akshat you know he went 50% so he
finished it four and a half yeah
respectful yeah yeah unfortunate he
stopped it very well he was the leading
player up until you know round five and
then it went downhill from there yeah
started very well and they just kind of
slowed down yeah it may have been an
attrition factor you know where you just
run out of steam yeah exactly so let's
look at P DS game real quick just to see
what is going on here
they made time time control for the
moves and it looks like we have an
opposite color bishop however white
these two pawns up
so definitely white is the one who is
playing for the win here production
kinda pan I would say cannot win this
one that's that's for sure so he can
only draw so he is fighting for that for
a draw and if pre-adoption draws his
game he is going to be sharing the place
he's only have six points that's correct
so definitely this is an important game
to look at but right now I don't like I
don't like black black odds in this
position so pawn takes on g5 was just
played and it looks to me that White's
ideas will be probably to try to create
another passport or the king is going to
come here to eat to g6 the question is
is this pawn on e6 makes a difference so
let's try to make some moves
well black theoretically black has no
plan here I mean I cannot move my kima
king has to stay here on f7
to defend all this pawn chain coming in
whether this this Bishop on g7 looks a
little bit awkward and I wonder if
if there's any chance here for for black
to make a drug just because of this
Bishop on g7 if I will put the Bishop
from g7 to be five this will be probably
much much easier win for white so right
now it looks like black is restricting
this Bishop on g7 okay let's make some
moves for for black route Bishop d1 and
will help take King to c5 maybe this one
will allow a five but what will be my
plan here let's see if I go to e5
instead I'm just gonna wait
well actually I cannot put the bishop
here on on e too because then it will
allow white to play a four he white
creates another passport but this is it
so I probably have to keep my Bishop on
this diagonal so Bishop to c2 into the
six Bishop to d1 and now the question
how do I make progress other make
progress if I play King to c5 try to
come to b6 Bishop d3 a for now I wonder
if this pawn might help so for example a
five take taken out efore and this this
pawn might be a huge difference between
a loss and a draw but I still feel like
white has better options here and judge
the Bullock definitely has the time of
the cloth to figure this out what would
be the best plan here for white and what
else can we do here okay I can move the
bishop for h6
that's gonna help me a lot let's go back
to d6 he's going to stay here
well another thing in this position
there might be some zoos one ideas so
for example so Zubrin is when does not
have a very good move
so in this case white can my plate g6
check forcing the Queen the King out and
Keane takes on a secret I do f7 and
promoting so the fact is that is that in
such positions black has to keep his
Bishop on c2 covering g6 and covering a
four but I don't think that black has
this choice because let's say Bishop e3
in d6 now Bishop c2 covering those two
squares but white probably has just
regular move something like let's see
where can I put my my bishop maybe
Bishop h8
it will be a good move and now the
bishop has to move and I either have to
I have to go away from protecting the a
Foursquare all the logistics go so for
example if I go here now wife gets this
passport again and if black goes here to
d1 that I might again play g6 King takes
and King takes only six this looks very
very winning for for white although
opposite color bishops usually end up in
a in a draw but here just those those
passports are doing great job in
promoting themselves so I would expect
that white will win this game it's going
to go for a while but actually I don't
think that that White's White's plan is
so difficult after white took here on g5
I think that we had a few moves have
been made ok so let's look at this
position what has happened this should
be 3 and now g6 Jacksonville decides to
sag the pawn that's interesting and now
playing Bishop to e3
well looking at the camera
Jack just made this move and he looks
very confident I got apple of his chair
hey where do you see him yeah yeah when
you make it when you make a move and you
can stand up then that that means that
you know it's it's a good move but I
don't see I don't see why why had to
sacrifice this pawn too big quite
understand
now black estate came to f7 okay well
now wife is only one pawn up so let's
try to figure this out well is this
Bishop gonna go Bishop d6 let's try to
make it some some more egg as some more
waiting moves and now came to d6 okay so
I think I figured out Jack's idea he
wants to put Bishop on e5 defending this
pawn this King has to stay here on f7
and now the White King will simply go to
be six a5 and push a 4 B 5 and just come
all this de-spawn and black will have to
sacrifice his Bishop Allen for the pawn
now by the way something important
probably will not happen but this one or
h4 if it's going to be the last men
standing from all of White's pawns it is
good that it is promoting to the adult
square with this bishop just in case
just in case if black is going to have
some kind of ideas of sacrificing the
bishop we had a few moves have been
played Bishop d4 has been played yeah so
everything is going by the plan and I
wonder I want to know if black and try
to sacrifice his pawn back
so Bishop a4 was played King d6 and now
can I go fight this ball would that help
me because if I sacrifice this pawn on
e5 that said Bishop takes the Bishop e3
at least the bishop can somehow cover
this the squirrel and f7 but I think
that even here
it won't be enough so let's bring the
bishop somewhere back let's make some
surrender move the King will simply go
here and now he has to defend this pawn
now a4 probably will go here and then b5
take take and the pawn is just running
and yeah those two passports will be
very difficult very difficult to stop I
don't I don't see a way for for black
dude to say this disposition
unless obviously white blunders but
again Jack the extra bullet has been
proven himself yes a very sharp layer
and with enough time on the clock I
don't see any problem yeah there should
be no problem and if he wins he'll
suddenly be up in a three-way tie for
fourth with four and a half points not
too bad for his first st. Louis outing
yeah okay so I'm going back let's see
what other games do we have we have JJ
morandi reading aaron grab in ski in
group b so good good for JJ this this
last one d6 was very nice because it
really suffocated this Bishop on d8
there's no way for him to move the
bishop and the King has to go backwards
that's the only move EA to see it and
then white can can bring his king and
this is a very nice tool in the game
what about group a this is a game that's
going on your own share book and daro
spirits let's look at this game to slew
gentlemen yeah your friends are playing
each other yes yes
h4 okay so let's look at this position
what do we have here well black is a
pawn up so far
and looks like black is doing pretty
well I like this truck on d3 having the
king very active rook
I like the king of the Bishop Heelan on
d5 the book both players have under a
minute on the clock but this is move
number 38 so they only need to do two
moves and you can see that they're both
both very concentrated on the chest work
there is made a move something went back
so the rook went back to d4 so king of
was played route to d4 attacking this
pawn on therefore bishop takes a three
was played and yarrow has made his 40th
move and they expect a collector take on
a four check and the king will have to
decide where to go now I cannot go to e2
because I will lose the Jeep on so
probably the King has to go to g1 and
that is going to be a complicated game
but definitely the Irish is the one
who's playing for win
I don't think that you know has any
chances he might have some chances for
survival but I really really doubt that
so we might have another decisive game
so no no draw so far no we've had draw
yeah okay
Bru's own and Akopian right and then
grupe a wonder and Chandra crew right
that's true not see elsewhere though I
mean there are there are two other games
still going on in Group A outside of
this one
Surya Ganguly against Sam Shanklin Sam
Franklin of course has a book signing
coming up tomorrow here in st. Louis for
small steps to chest improvement it's
all about the pawns
yes and the book is not available yet
you know maybe a black market item I
don't know but you can get it signed by
Sam tomorrow at the Chess Club
you you and me Ben we're gonna buy 50
books yes anybody yes
market up 5 bucks a pop no it'll be good
and Sam has been one of one of the
favorite most well-known players here in
st. Louis of course a well-known u.s.
championship competitor over the years
many years over so that'll be exciting
and I know seems really proud of that
book it's his first book yeah
those engines to him yeah okay so that's
that cease position then yeah that's his
pawn structure today
looks like Sam is upon down in this case
but he does have the two bishops and he
does have more time so Bishop c5 was
just played in the game and I wonder can
I take this polysix what is going on
here if I just take this another part on
a6
what is Sam's plan maybe Bishop c4 this
would allow white to check on f6
this is one of those games that you have
no idea what's gonna was gonna happen
the two bishops might get very strong
this Bishop on g3 is not the best he is
defending the e5 phone but right now is
just blocked locked here in on g3 the
nine only two is pretty passive so I'm
sure that that Zoey is thinking here
should I take this pawn a6 is it
poisoned I wonder if Sam has a chapter
about poison points yeah yeah it's gonna
be interesting on how that's you know
what how did they play this how did they
get this position he 45 Knight to c3
this is the closed Sicilian one of my
favorites when I was a well when I was
young in my good old days I used to play
it all the time a nice nice surprise but
it does poses to the open one to the
Saturday dragon maybe three and I think
that like does not have many problems
here with a short castle the dragon is
coming back making making a comeback
more and more people are playing the
dragon it's also sounds good yeah I feel
thing the dragon I mean if you're
playing the dragon all the Hedgehog
which one would you choose
well in theory yeah that's true I used
to play the joy the Hedgehog myself
first like 95
looks like both of the players have
played very well this is the typical
idea Sam did get some kind of play I
like his position check to convey to you
see some win exchanges here
so that's where the first word upon went
out
this is probably the day this is
probably the moment maybe that well
black offered an unofficial draw I would
say if you look at the if here white
like the movie 597 if were to play Roxy
for but black has nothing else to do so
much because this pin is just too strong
and that would probably have to repeat
the moves but instead so yes I said no I
want to play for a win there should be
seven Luke 8 three Roxy 4 so again white
is apana but black has the compensation
of two bishops now we had a few
exchanges the Kings coming in for
assistance black does make made it has
made some progress with the bishops
there should be 6f 495 they exchanged
one night very very complicated game so
let's let's let's look just in case to
get the the best view and he did take
this politics okay interesting
and now it it is Sam's turn
he's probably thinking well it was
supposed to be a poison pole but what
kind of poison yeah exactly so I don't
see immediately right now for black any
can tell any moves that can win a pole
although you can start up in Bishop to
b4 check let's start to check the pond
check the king just to check if I go to
d1 trying to defend the c2 upon then
black can play rook to d7 keen to see
one
maybe Rudy to Bishop d2 looks good check
here and if I go to beat to rock to b7
and March the king all the way from a 1
to a 1 and now I'm not quite sure I want
to meet you on c3 but the 9 is defending
the square so let's attack the knight
one time and in addition we're also
going to be attacking the rook
this one looks dead lost for white so I
think that wife has to be careful here
if he's going to get checked here on
before because in this case maybe I will
reconsider my option going to defend the
pawn here on the 1 defend despondency -
maybe I have to play it safe just to
take into f1 let's start to take this
pawn let's see if I can I actually
cannot take this pawn because of this
small tactic ro takes on e6 and guess
what
so yeah we'll get forward yeah that's
not something you want to do yes oh yeah
so King f1 is an option and again like
you can play Bishop c4 attacking the the
knight and the rope
but I can move my rock somewhere we
check on there for six Oh actually I
have f6 that's an interesting solution
for my problems I'm going to just get a
discovered check over here
let's go attack I don't know it's very
very complicated I think it's going to
come down to the time pressure although
they did pass the 40 moves but so yeah I
think so here has only 17 minutes we're
probably going to see some time pressure
in the next few moves right yeah so it's
gonna be interesting to see what is
going to happen there
all right let's see what else do we have
Alex EP Tov and Roman Edouard okay I
just want to look at his first move
today cuz I remember I told him okay are
you gonna play something like that HD
today there was no such move played okay
but okay he did it through the night but
the night is so birthday the sobel night
that goes into the center perfect so 9
ft then g3 we had this fetch shadow
style position and now c3 looks like
everybody is coming from each other for
the first few moves 6 moves
94 yeah as you can see this game looks
pretty equal nothing too much going on
he 5 this is a black suede saying he
four they went just to a simple end game
just change your old pieces white is
slightly better now because of this 996
will get stacked the phone gets attacked
on b7 you know that just reminds us that
copying from your opponent is not good
for black right yeah we should have fun
to the bishop still white is better
movie six disposition definitely white
is putting some pressure and a few
changes
into d3 prove to f-22 C 2 into F 4 check
check and this is the current position
it is why to move
alexandros move right now so let's see
what is going on here they just made
move number 40 so both of them got their
30 minutes extra on the clock you know
what they say Ben all of rocks and games
are Jewish so it does look like it's
going to be ending the draw we have
equal material if the King will take
this pawn the five I'm going to snap
this one of the of the board even if I
don't have this a three point that's
probably enjoy as well but this is very
very easy to draw
so King g7 was just made I don't see
another way for white to make any
progress here
that's a French the board just in case
yeah I don't see any any any progress
that's why can make here you can try to
take on a five with the rook let's see
if that works
what am I going to do now okay I'm just
gonna wait so the problem here is that
if you take with the rope here I can
check you on before check and I can
bring my rope to a four so the rooks are
the most the most effective behind upon
supporting the pole and actually now
White has no chance to stop this pawn so
taking on the five is super super
dangerous with a rope
so probably white would have to take the
point either with the King or the play
d4 but you know the result would be the
same they came to have to go back we are
going to see this this this ending
coming in and my expectation is that
this game is going to be ending in a
draw it's a fair assessment I mean in
this this game was not one of the the
big ones when I'm in today yeah alright
it was not gonna have a factor on the
top spot but it still it was great
seeing both of these players eat the
table has played in here in st. Louis a
few times before and I mean he's
basically a st. Louis guy now yeah
Romana édouard first time in st. Louis
from France it was really cool seeing
him you know he yeah we've seen him on
the international broadcast of chess
tournaments so it was good to see him
here in st. Louis good nice nice little
run that's my man oh we hope to see them
again let's see who else do we have
it's go to the game of the day in Group
B the adoption can upon the versus Ajax
Tambu duck our new game of the day
tonight the old game of the day we
hardly knew ye yeah yes
so Bishop so as we said the white did
get this pawn on d5 he did
succeed in creating a passport also
here's another this f6 bond and I just
don't see away how can we stop this pawn
king to b6 was just played and okay you
won't believe this but the machine
suggests that in this position white has
a mate in 32 moves how do you miss that
31 no yeah it's an even more efficient
than 31 moves but basically the idea is
pretty easy the the white king is going
to come to a7 you cannot stop me the
pawn is going to come to to b6 and just
go forward and in Queen black we'll have
to try to second second
Bishop but this is pretty much it
so I expect that Jack Stanwyck will win
this game any game that we haven't
discussed yet today that's we've gone
around the horn here but let's has
anything happened in durable and
Darrow's game let's see yes the day that
makes a few moves let's go back to where
we where we we stopped after the move of
the time control has been made around
this moment take and route to d2 he did
not take on the the point of fall but
there is played this move rook to d2 he
actually is going for the Jeep on and a
two point okay that's a pretty good plan
Bishop to e7 the rook takes a to take
take maybe we have seen a few exchanges
and this is the current position and now
black wants to take on h3 and again lead
having the lead of two points looks
pretty good for black very good we do
see PD or the other on the screen right
now and it looks like that you know when
you have this posture it's like okay my
my eyes I mean now or do I suffer for
another half an hour and I feel like
okay I was expected to resign but he was
able still try his best
so going back to euros game let's see if
white has any chance to draw maybe I
need to try to exchange the rooks but I
don't see a way how I don't see a way
how do i how do I save this pawn HT
let's go for this pon da tonight let's
just try to get this pawn bishop takes
the problem is that this pawn on c7 is
really not important it's a double pawn
you know black doesn't really need that
and now I'm afraid that the bishop might
just go to e6 just to secure this pawn
on c4 and now my king is gonna come in
to e4 take this pawn on a4 or King to f3
together with the stroke on a to this
King on g1 feels helpless hopeless
helpless
maybe both maybe both although less and
I yeah I doubt that white will find a
plan how to draw this it's a it could be
super difficult this would be a very big
surprise to me if you survive this
so Darius right now he has 4 points
yes he has four points right now so if
he wins he's gonna have five points
together with who are in second place
right anybody else this was five points
yes looks like speedy PD is losing so
he's gonna have yeah over in Group B PD
is losing yeah and so he'll be stuck at
five and a half which is gonna be clear
third for him that's all bad no it's
very good very good I mean these are
these are strong these are strong fields
by tally I mean by the feed a rating
coming in this is the at least the
Masters I'm pretty sure the B is to the
strongest of the classic tournaments
we've had yet and we started this series
one year ago almost to the day with the
Winter Classic so this is the fourth one
we've had and we're on track to have
three more this year with the different
classics that should be a lot of fun and
these tournaments they serve a very
specific purpose you know it's not like
the grand chest or where we're seeing
the elite players these are the 2600
grandmasters and a lot of times and
they're not all grandmasters are two non
grandmasters in these fields but these
players often get overlooked because of
the elite vitality yeah yeah that's
that's true and you know I was just
wondering if I would not be working here
as the game master resident I would
maybe be the maybe plea thing yeah maybe
you guys would invite me instead of
Aaron yeah I mean I mean those norms
right right right
Aaron the grip in ski who hasn't had a
impressive tournament but I mean all
things considered
Aaron helped make this tournament happen
exactly if you if it wasn't him I mean
you can't just make it to LA with nine
players would it be a round-robin
anymore right we needed so grand master
James Tarzan was originally supposed to
be in Group B the the chess player the
the librarian himself and he could not
come to
illness so we had nine players and well
we need someone who's strong we need
someone who's ready and Willie who's in
the area there's not enough time to
travel and so a group in ski picks up
the slack so yeah we're very happy
Malakal luckily we do have here two
University teams for Webster and from
slow so there's plenty of chess players
had to choose from and yeah so good for
them oh very good and uh while we're
wrapping things up here I'd like to talk
about some upcoming events here at the
Chess Club that you'll be watching all
over the world because they're big
they're real big first of all one of the
events that has a direct relation may be
an indirect relation to this tournament
is the US Chess Championship it's just
Christmas here in st. Louis Oh coming up
next month the US Chess Championship
will feature all five of American
players in Group A and it will feature
one of the players in Group E wonderland
so that will be a lot of fun and not
just that vitality it will also feature
Wesley so yeah Fabiano Cara Juana
I got and Hikaru Nakamura the big three
of American chess you think back like
ten years ago the US Chess Championship
was impressive but it wasn't on fire
like it is these days yeah everybody's
almost twenty one twenty eight hundred
three players yes yeah so and they
wonder Olympian last last year into the
2016 Olympic yeah Sam Shanklin is a part
of that I mean how can we forget to
mention that there's so much going on in
u.s. chess
oh it looks like we have a decision here
yeah I was almost five probably
resignation from Peavy yes okay he had a
very good very good tournament by the
way no losses up until this moment I'm
put in the ninth round I think that he
had no losses it's okay I think that is
probably going to finish in fourth place
or third place still very very good
results for him
and back to the US Championship what
we're talking about coming up next month
it will be broadcast on us chess champs
calm right where you're watching this on
our youtube channel as well the US Chess
Federation it has released a poll and
it's like who's gonna win Wesley so
mm-hmm Cara wanna Nakamura the rest of
the field that's just all one option
it's it's uh it's it's crazy strong you
know at the top yeah so that's gonna be
the one last year last year it was
Wesley so last I saw so there here's a
resurgence the way I remember it in the
st. Louis years Nakamura Chomsky Chomsky
Nakamura Chomsky Chomsky Nakamura Cara
Juana so there you go
and now we're on the 10th anniversary of
the club the 10th edition of the u.s.
championship at the club started in 2009
and it's always so much fun there's
people who come from out of town to
watch this event and why not you make
st. Louis your vacation next month yeah
oh ho yeah yeah I'm here to like it
stick around
yeah exactly it's more than the Central
West attitude st. Louis is a great city
it's a it's it's probably because I came
here for for school my wife came in for
school she's from New York and we both
stayed here well I stayed because of the
Chess Club and she stayed because of me
so that's how we get people over here
and at this moment I will also like to
thank the st. Louis Chess Club for
giving me the opportunity to get to do
the live commentary and this this show I
also would like to thank all the staff
and especially you been as you know this
so this was my first time to do live
commentary and you know what they say
you never forget the first time yeah
it's a lot of fun here we've had a lot
of fun for this tournament yeah I would
also like to thank my family for the
support and watching the show and all of
my friends also especially they like to
convey
my brother Danny for finishing his
military service tomorrow so love you
daddy
the other man and finally we are ending
this show this is the last day of the
show but I will be staying here as the
gamemaster resident for the until the
end of March I will be coming back
afterwards hopefully but I'm gonna have
some more time instead of doing live
commentary I'm going to be doing some
lectures here for kids and adults I'm
also going to be responsible for the
private lessons so please if anybody
wants to get you know together feel
please
we can go come to this English chess
club get a private lesson by the way the
private lessons for staff as well yeah
so ok deal work yeah and if you would
like to know some more information about
me you can go on my website it's called
powerful chess calm you can need some
more information to contact me or you
can contact directly the Chess Club I'm
also available for online lessons you
know that's a pretty big thing nowadays
you don't have to be local to get an
online lesson it's awesome exactly you
just wake up on Sunday morning in your
pajamas you turn on the computer and you
get a lesson why not
so you also have weekly lectures here at
the club brightness oh I know that dare
I say is it tomorrow you're gonna do the
Alpha zero lecturer you said we we
actually had a strategy session
yesterday which was in Tuesday's I
believe tomorrow we are going to have
the secret life of pawns yes and we're
also going to have play like a pro trail
at the pro could you I I'm not sure can
can you can you describe alpha zero as a
pro you know I think it's a pretty Pro
yeah I think maybe I think for your
topic yeah I think we'll accept it you
know
alpha zero itself I don't know what its
gonna do with money yeah sounds good I
it's gonna be either tomorrow or next
week I definitely want to include alpha
zeros match with stock fish I think it's
incredible I'm Pro alpha zero and I
think that we as humans you know we
shouldn't be scared of technology but we
just need to cooperate with technology
hand-to-hand and I think both of us can
learn from each other yeah this is
definitely from them as well for sure so
there's a there's a lot going on here
yeah I also have to mention coming up
after the US Championship it's the grand
chest tour and first we're going to kick
it off with Paris and living in in
France and Belgium and then the
Grantchester comes through st. Louis and
this year the st. Louis rapid and blitz
comes before the Sinquefield Cup
starting on August 9th
now we fell in love with this tournament
last year remember the return of Garry
Kasparov oh yeah who still was
impressive for someone who hasn't played
chess and well over a decade he even got
a universal rating out of that so that's
pretty play lose erected in the top
thirty or something like that and then
after the rapid and blitz
we have the Sinquefield Cup it's the
sixth edition it starts right after the
rapid and blitz and it is the only
classical tournament in the Grand chest
tour this year the only one that's all
classical and of course will have the
London final in December that event will
be the top four finishers playing in a
knockout style match system how exciting
how exciting you know and all of those
tournaments they're all broadcasted live
and the commentators are usually yes
I'll say one writer Jennifer Schack yeah
for the US for the upcoming tournaments
we have yasser we have Jen we have
Maurice the dream team the originals and
coming up next before even the US
Championship we have quite the treat for
you because there's a little tournament
in Berlin Germany going on right now the
2018 candidates tournament who's gonna
play Magnus Carlsen at the end of
this year and there you see it our
coverage of the candidates tournament
begins in round 10 on March 22nd
we'll have round 10 11 12 13 14
yes 14 rounds there will be a rest day
somewhere in there
one round a day and there will be a
playoff if necessary it won't be like
two years ago there will be playoff
they're tied at the top only one can
play Magnus Carlsen and so it should
feel like it the the playoff is what's
really exciting to me gen Shehadeh
yasser sara Juan and Maurice Ashley will
be here for the call starting on March
22nd today in chess okay so this
broadcast had a lot of had a lot of
people working with it and I want to
give some shoutouts but before we look
at our standings to it first of all
international arbiters Tony rich and
Mike comer keeping things all smooth
determine Holly yes absolutely no
incidents no no casualties right I'd
like to thank Ryan Chester and Dennis
LaRue although they weren't working
directly with the broadcast today they
were getting us interview some other
days we got to give a shout out to Beth
Deakin who is making sure that all the
players hospitality needs were met
that's one of the big things they keep
them happy yeah the players comfort for
sure okay now before we close this show
let's take a look at the final standings
as much as we're gonna get them yeah
Group a now there are three games still
going but what we know right now is that
Alexander ownership has clinched fourth
place pardon me that is not 100% a sure
thing yet but right now he sits at four
points in third place right now if if I
may let me say that Lazaro burrs own of
Cuba stands at four and a half points
the third place prize which it's not
final for him yet is $2,000 remember
those three other games could
come up with a leapfrog er I do think
that one of the games is going to be
decisive maybe Dahlia spirits will beat
yellow gel I think that one of them will
finish with with five points also the
also Sam's game was you know pretty
exciting so I think that's one of one of
those players that are still waiting for
yourself we'll have the five points and
probably will get to the second place
yeah so really it's impossible to talk
about prize breakdown right now vara
Cobian right now has second live but
yeah he could be joined by someone
probably will be but just look at the
Jefferies six and a half points that's
like yes we do know without a doubt our
champion of the 2018 spring chess
classic group a grandmaster
Jeffrey Zhong a seventeen year old from
Texas the Dallas area Jeffrey is a
former US Junior champion won the title
here in st. Louis world junior champion
from 2016 and he has a great future
ahead of him and we look forward to
having him and more of these classic
traveling yeah so six grand for Jeffrey
and now group B let's take a look at how
things break down there it's a little
bit easier because everything has been
decided in the tenth place we have
Nashville master Erin Griffin ski he
walks away with $500 Grand Master
Alexander fear of Brazil gets $500 as
well we have a two-way tie for seventh
place these players will split $1,700
I'm sorry
$1,100 I wonder learing and JJ a lemur
Andy a three-way tie for fourth place
Hachi and Chandra Timberlake first time
we saw Jack Tremblay what do you think
of his performance in this tournament
yeah I think it was pretty pretty good
now remember and look he's only not only
but he's an international master
fighting within all those grandmasters
so finishing tying for the fourth place
is pretty good especially this is for
first time here in the US insane
Louis very impressive I would say it's a
pretty good result having a 50% very
nice now those three players will each
split $800 we do have a little bit of a
mix-up at the top you'll notice we love
canopy and so much we put in a second
but canopy is actually in third place
right and with five and a half points he
will walk away with 50 points are
correct yes he's just not than other
places and Andre Corbett's is actually
our second place finisher the Belarusian
with six points we'll leave with two
thousand dollars and finally he finished
it early grand master victory collapse
key of Israel with first place seven
points
he got the win today and leaves with 25
I'm sorry
$4,000 $4,000 is his grand prize seven
points not too bad
yes yeah I know I staggered some of
those prizes there forgive me but this
has been a great tournament guys we want
to thank just everybody who's been
involved this production was brought to
you by the world's greatest B team Tammy
Hyde is on om names there look at that
oh yeah we are
Tammy height is our technical advisor
Jonathan shruts right there look at here
means good to see Jonathan I was always
smiling yeah you get those interviews
the floor manager if you will Isaac's
rants with graphics and audio danny
Machuca is our technical director my
name is Ben Simon and I've got a
neighbor and we want to remind you once
again the candidates tournament coverage
begins March 22nd right here at us chest
champs calm and it's gonna be great each
day will start at noon with Jen yasser
and more Reese so until then this is us
saying so long from the show-me-state
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you